hello everybody my name is ezra pryor
and
i'm here today to talk to you about
research stigma
and regulations oh my um
i tell you a little bit about myself
here i'm the applied market specialist
at hindolf north america in their
uh hbx unit the hideoff botanical
extractions unit so we focus
specifically on the cannabis market
and how to better serve that market with
premium laboratory equipment
i'm also the past chair founder
and current development chair of the
cannabis chemistry subdivision
at the american chemical society um
i also would like to introduce dr j han
marku
who although he could not be here to
help me present the
material today i was instrumental in
helping me put this together
he was also a co-founder of the cannabis
chemistry subdivision at the american
chemical society
with me so many years ago at this point
he is the editor-in-chief of the
american journal of endocannabinoid
medicine
[Music]
he is also working with the in
international research center
on cannabis and health and he currently
serves as the historian
for can so
um you know i'll start this presentation
with a quote
so amy purdy said if we can see past
our preconceived limitations then
possibilities are endless
and amy purdy famously was the
para paralympic athlete who had
two prosthetic legs um and she gave this
ted talk it was great
with these oversized uh
and you know crescent-shaped uh
prostheses the legs and
i think it's amazing um to sort of think
past
what we're replacing when we face
limitations
you know so when we deal with those
limitations we can have end up with
advantages and i think so that's a
really good
way to get this started so we're going
to be looking at the cannabis industry
and where we are currently at in march
of
2020 and
where we see things going with the
guidance
and support of nonprofits and other
institutions that are helping to to
build this industry
in a very specific way um
yeah so when we're looking at the
industry today uh
you know it doesn't matter what you
accomplished yesterday
um it's only about where you're at today
right where is what's your level of
compliance today what's your level of
you know readiness today what's your
level of agreement with other
laboratories today and
things like that um and i think that
there are some companies that are doing
research
there are some companies that are really
putting in that that energy
and there's others that aren't and i
think that that's going to be
a significant advantage moving forward
um and there are these hurdles that
we're dealing with
uneven uh unpredictable regulations
um policy stigma is still an issue we're
dealing with although it is
um you know quickly lifting and
we want to understand really what are
the pains that the industry is facing
at the moment and how are these
non-profits addressing those
those issues so here's a number of
things that
the industry is facing right now so
there's a lack of clear federal guidance
there's state oversight certainly
but there are resources that are
being withheld in a way when the federal
government is not participating
in that regulatory oversight in a lot of
ways
it is in some ways but you know we'll
get into that
there's a lack of resources
for the state regulatory oversight
agencies
a lot of times they don't understand the
challenge that they're trying to
overcome with uh the actual size of the
of the cannabis operations and the
number of them
in a specific state so we finding a lot
of states are struggling to
develop the resources to actually have
regulatory oversight and
um you know support those facilities uh
there's an inconsistency with regards to
methods and practices
so this is both in testing and
manufacturing when you don't have
a consistent set of methods then from
batch you know from one facility to
another facility you could have
a significantly different results this
is a
particularly issue with testing because
if you don't have a specific method that
is repeated
in different laboratories the numbers
might not add up
you know you could have two different
laboratories producing two different
results
because they're doing different methods
of analysis
because there isn't a wide widely
accepted
method of analysis in every case there's
also
an issue with isolation of scientists
so people can feel
unconnected i mean when you think about
um
you know plastics chemistry or something
like something
you know banal if you will um you know
those scientists
typically don't find any barriers to
interacting
uh with each other and uh with other
scientists in their
uh department or company but with
cannabis
sometimes the stigma can get in the way
of of that communication and that
networking and that connectedness
that uh creates opportunities for
collaboration
and you know brainstorming things like
that
so uh you know the last issue i'll bring
up is
inconsistent and unreliable product so
because there
again are so many variations on method
you can find that there's a lot of uh
inconsistency in the product
um and you know one product is available
for some amount of time and then not
available
or you know one gummy bear is not the
same as another gummy bear
so inconsistency within a batch
inconsistency between similar products
things like that are a challenge in the
industry at the moment
so you know we're going to talk about
different solutions
for those specific issues so there is
some work happening with federal
agencies
there are development of regulatory
oversights
and strategies for states to have
better resources or more efficiently
using their resources
um there are development of standards
and methods and practices
and um you know that's going to be a
really interesting thing to
to come back to there are efforts to
connect
scientists and lastly there are
developments of
quality assurance and quality control
standards
so we're going to get into those
and then again you know we're in an
imperfect industry
um you know some
laboratories for example um are getting
limited engagements
because they're seeing you know the the
producers
are seeing testing as an as an
opportunity
to uh verify the value that they've
asserted
or demonstrate that they have less value
right they're not necessarily seeing it
as a value-added proposition
or they're just interested in testing
potency
so where testing is not always mandated
it can be real challenge for these
laboratories to develop
um you know another thing that we're
dealing with
is this vape crisis that we've narrowly
escaped
um there were some you know bad actors
in the in the vape cart uh
segment of the cannabis industry and
thanks to pax and other institutions
that were um doing research publishing
that research and
letting people know what really was
going on
uh so that's you know that's was a
stumbling uh
you know a stumbling block and
you know there's limited research i'm
sorry limited support for research
and publications oftentimes we find
people
who've done fantastic research and
they're
having a hard time getting published
because they're dealing with
um an older generation that doesn't take
this
particular material seriously and so
you know we've got publishers that are
not being
open-minded about the value of
presenting cannabis research so
you know there's also a cbd credibility
problem
the market was really flooded in the
last few years
and so it can be difficult to you know
separate the wheat from the chaff right
and i think that moving forward
these cbd companies are going to have an
opportunity to build that credibility
um or not and in the end the
cbd companies with credibility are going
to last and the other ones are going to
you know be a flash in the pan
and you know there's impending federal
oversight there's
there seems to be this um
i don't even know how to put it right
there's there's there seems to be this
looming threat
of federal oversight you know eventually
we're going to have to deal with the
oversight of the federal government
which uh you know on the one hand
there's tremendous resources there
for support and development and uh
but on the other hand it can be
daunting because we don't know exactly
how they're going to operate
we can look at parallel industries we
can look at you know similar situations
so we're not completely in the dark here
but it does seem to be um
you know topic of conversation and it
seems to be sort of an inevitability
almost right
so um you know something to think about
too
is how we're overcoming this knowledge
gap
and the some of these issues is that
there are universities that are
popping up left and right with training
modules for cannabis
analysis for cannabis cultivation
for extraction and things like that so
i think this is going to be a valuable
resource moving forward
and i'm eager to see how those
universities
interact with private industry
and you know how they they serve
synergize right
and this is one of my favorite slides
this is the
numerous non-profits of influence and of
course i couldn't mention all of them
but these are the six that i found
to be most relevant in my work and in
the development of the industry at this
point uh of course i've got to mention
the american chemical society's cannabis
chemistry subdivision
first and foremost because that's so
near and dear to my heart
but we also have the aoac the aocs
astm international usp and ahp
and we're going to take a minute and
look at each one of those
and see what they're working on and how
they overlap
and things like that so yeah this is a
nifty venn diagram
that is going to show us you know who's
doing what right
so you can see astm is right in the
center there
with their finger in every pie
and we'll get into how they would manage
to be
so diverse in their efforts in a little
bit
we have usp who's working on quality
control
identification strength and purity and
then we have
ahp that's working on identity quality
control and analytical methods
and then we have the aocs and aoac we're
both focused specifically on
development of analytical methods uh and
then
can is the lone wolf off to the side
working specifically on networking
professional development mentorship
collaboration recognition
and really bringing the the
people who are doing everything right to
the table so that they can be heard
and you know enriching that talent pool
uh
for the next for the next generation of
cannabis scientists
so again i'm going to sort of put
american chemical societies cannabis
chemistry subdivision
front and foremost um you know
the american chemical society is the
largest scientific society
uh with 150 000 people plus worldwide if
i'm not mistaken
and right now we have 70 plus members
i'm sorry 700 plus members i'm gonna
move the decimal place there
um and we're dedicated to uh cannabis
chemistry
and
scientists and so uh let's see we're um
yeah we serve the scientific community
uh and
create opportunities for collaboration
uh we
provide a way into the industry for a
lot of
professionals as well as a way up in the
industry for a lot of people who are
already in
the cannabis industry as as scientists
um
and uh there's an acs national meeting
every six months that
we just had one cancelled due to
coronavirus
but typically every six months we put
together
two full days of programming that are
published works and they may not have
been published if it wasn't for us
coming together together and bringing
these people to the table
um and you know we also make an effort
to recognize scientists that are
doing exceptional work with the el solle
awards sponsored by hideoff north
america
and this is the first cannabis chemistry
award
so i'm really happy to be a part of that
because we've made some history there
and so just a
you know a couple fun pictures of us
doing some cool stuff at uh at the
american chemical society's cannabis
chemistry subdivision
um down at the bottom left you can see
the el solley award sponsored by high
off north america
winners with dr mahmoud el-soli the
namesake of the award
in front and center and then the
four people holding plaques are the
award winners for that year and
that was that was last year 2019. above
that you can see
stephen goldman who's on the far left
next to me in the bottom left picture
giving that presentation up top um
in the center you can see the parade
that we held in new orleans
uh on the way to the networking event we
had a uh
an acs national meeting in new orleans
and um
i had the idea that you know it's in new
orleans
you can have a parade for anything in
new orleans right so why not have a
parade from the convention center
to our networking event so that was a
good time we had a
a band leading the way and everything um
and then bottom right is one of our more
typical networking events
that i believe was the cannabis science
conference
uh associated networking event so
that's a really great opportunity to get
scientists together and help collaborate
uh
you know foster collaboration and
networking and whatnot
so next i want to do one quick little
success story because
really can is about people and so
it you know we don't want to miss uh
we don't want to miss out on looking at
exactly what what's the effect of this
and i think this is a great opportunity
um
you know dr elizabeth wagner is a good
friend of mine
and uh a wonderful scientist who was
working in petroleum
and wasn't really happy with what she
was doing
and uh i think before she
knew us she didn't know that cannabis
was really a viable option
but because she came to our networking
events because she got to meet other
people who had
you know stable and gainful employment
as cannabis scientists she was able to
learn about that
and so we were able to sort of like
tempt her to the dark side right
and get her to join the cannabis
industry now she works in the testing
lab
and then i'll just read this quote off
for you and she says i go to a lot of
networking events
and can is always really good at making
that balance between having fun
and getting to know folks in a
professional setting and i love that
about canned events
so um so basically because she was
coming to networking events
you know she she
met the person who hired her she moved
to a new city and she called me up and
she said ezra
you know how can i find a place in the
cannabis industry in
boston that's where i'm moving and i
said well you already know
chris hudala at proverty labs because
you met at
this other networking event right so um
she was able to
have already met that person i was able
to make uh you know
refresh that that relationship with an
email because i know the both of them
uh you know and that's how it works
right um
so moving on i admittedly know less
about
some of these other organizations
because i'm not directly involved in
their success
but they're very important nonetheless
so the
american association of agricultural
chemists the aoac
is working specifically as i mentioned
before on analytical methods
um and you know this is going to be
critical
because they're developing these methods
that people are going to use
when testing cannabis and at a certain
point
we're going to have to adopt a set of
methods
and as an industry we're going to have
to say okay if you want potency testing
it's going to be this particular test
if you want terpene content testing it's
going to have to be this specific test
and those are going to compare between
laboratories because they're consistent
and it's the same method
[Music]
so the other component
is another organization is the american
oil chemistry society so again they're
working
specifically on methods of analysis um
and again you know these are going to
have to be rectified at some point
somebody's going to have to look at
these
these lists of standards and develop
what is a specifically you know an
approved set of
of methods for the entire industry
[Music]
and cynthia ludwig uh you know i know
her
personally she was a volunteer with
cannes uh
back before the efforts of the aoc
uh became so significant that she had to
focus on those
um so
another organization is the american
society of testing and materials
um and add international to that because
they want to be
uh not just known for their work in the
united states but
globally now they formed a
pretty significant committee the d37
committee which i'm a member
has more than 100 people so uh
how do you stay productive with more
than 100 people on a committee well it's
a challenge i can tell you that
but i think a great thing that they've
done is develop a number of
subcommittees so i apologize for this
tiny writing here
but there's so much to share
they've got all of these subcommittees
working on different components
of that those issues and that's how
the astm was able to stay in the very
center of that venn diagram where
they've got their finger in every pie
right they would be able to develop
subcommittees to deal with terminology
uh industrial hemp security and
transportation laboratory quality
management systems so on and so forth
so um and then on the right you have
finished standards so these are
standards that they've published
too many to number i'm sorry too many to
uh to write out completely because the
text would be so small
you need to put a magnifying glass up to
the to the screen to read it
um because you can see down at the
bottom those are all published standards
as well
and there are so many more that are
being worked on right now
so um next we have the united uh the
united states pharmacopoeia
so this is really an interesting
organization
they had a cannabis
pharmacopia cannabis was included in the
pharmacopoeia
so many years ago i think
70 years ago is when it was excluded and
um it was first mentioned in 1851 you
can see that
uh you know the the front cover of that
pharmaco
us pharmacopia edition 3 that included
cannabis
right because that was such an important
agricultural product in the united
states before prohibition
um and you know again these guys are
setting standards for identity strength
purity and uh of medicines food
ingredients
dietary supplements manufactured
distributed and consumed worldwide
so that's their goal overall and so you
can
see how cannabis falls into that goal
right and again
we were saying that they focused
specifically on identity
for um for their work
in the short term but usp has a really
interesting story
um you know they are a government
organization so
they're not the swiftest acting perhaps
um but certainly deliberate right so in
2015
they published a feasibility study about
publishing a
uh you know about including
cannabis in the u.s pharmacopoeia again
and they had a forum
they had an expert panel this is a two
years later already
and then the fda comes in and blocks the
usp publication of the in-house
in the in-house publication so the u.s
pharmacopoeia is
their publication right and the fda
basically says look you know we sign
your paychecks
uh you can't publish that here so
the fda i'm sorry the usp is then
submitting that work
um for quality uh
for quality of cannabis inflorescence um
in a separate journal in a separate
scholarly journal
it's currently under review so i can't
share with you unfortunately
what journal that is um i was hoping
that by the time i was recording this
presentation
we would have that publication out but
it is not
it's not there another slide i'd love to
talk to you about
is the american herbal pharmacopia
so the american herbal pharmacopia
is a guidebook
for dealing with specific crops and
specific plants
and there was a cannabis
edition of the american herbal
pharmacopoeia in 1850
originally released in 1850 and there
were
other editions until about 70 years ago
and then we were able to get one out
my colleague dr marku was instrumental
in
that process and it states the
standards for identity analysis and
quality control of cannabis
inflorescence
or flowers so that's a really
interesting read you can get that online
i believe it's a small download fee but
it's definitely worth it
if you're looking at standards and
when we look at these specific standards
i think that they're going to be
very helpful for us inferring what
we might get when we have federal
oversight
right because this document
draws from parallel industries
parallel crops that are regulated
federally
and and tries to present similar
standards
so lastly this is a tool that
you can use in a laboratory
that's privately owned or as an example
in the state of delaware a state agency
can use this to maximize the
efforts that they have and maximize the
resources that they have for regulatory
oversight
and to be completely transparent here
this is something that hide off north
america
sells so i'd be happy to talk to anybody
about this and i'm going to briefly show
you guys
what it can do so
we've got three screen shots from this
program
and basically it takes the regulations
that a cannabis operation needs to be um
aware of and uh in compliance with
and puts it into a easy to read
checklist format that's the bottom left
image and that's your self-assessment
so you can do that on an ipad you can go
through and do the self-assessment which
otherwise would have been a pen and
paper endeavor
and then automatically those results get
put into
uh a spreadsheet which is that central
image
with nested information like um
how to address that violation what is
the
regulatory citation specifically that
addresses to that issue
what is the potential cost for that
issue in the event of surprise
inspection
who you want to assign it to keeping
track of all those issues
managing those tasks and then lastly
there is
metadata that's generated instantly
where you can look at
issues over time issues by area
issues by category things like that
issues by
you know potential fines and that's that
you know multiple graph image in the top
right
and so what this is going to do is you
know
when you look at states that are trying
to
regulate a tremendous number of cannabis
facilities
this is an example of a tool that can
take that one auditor that has to look
at a thousand facilities
and change that paradigm significantly
because now
those facilities can self-audit and
report that info
those facilities can have a record of
their inspection with all that metadata
generated instantly
you know you don't have to have somebody
full time just generating that metadata
while you have other people full time
that are collecting that data right
so it's this type of innovation that's
really going to drive
compliance forward because you do have
people who are self-regulating do you
have do
have people who are you know really
aggressive about
staying in compliance and this is going
to help them do that
it's also going to help state regulators
keep up with the challenge right i think
and i want to throw any states under the
bus specifically
uh but there are some states where they
have 6000
uh cannabis operations
and six auditors you know so how are you
going to have
one person inspect a thousand facilities
it's not really possible but
if you can maximize that person's effort
by giving them some technological tools
then you can you know becomes a much
more manageable task
so i'd like to recap the non-profits of
influence that i
mentioned previously can
of course the cannabis chemistry
subdivision of the american chemical
society
is working on networking collaboration
publications and improving the applicant
pool
for the cannabis chemistry industry
specifically
the astm is working on standards of
quality potency identification methods
of analysis with their
mega committee the aocs
is working on methods of analysis the
ahp
is i working on identity quality and
methods of analysis the aoac
is working on methods of analysis and
the usp
is working on quality identity and
strength
so um you know i want to take a minute
to look to the future
and really so we can see what the issues
we're facing
today are and we can see what the
solutions
that are underway are some of them are
making a lot more progress than others
but you know there are there are these
solutions these
support systems that are making their
way
uh into the industry and
um you know self-regulation is happening
standards are being made right federal
oversight is coming it is an
inevitability in my opinion
um and then international bodies will
eventually
also adopt some sets of standards um
and then and it's something to think
about many will not survive
the transition to the new cannabis
industry
i think we've already seen a lot of
operations perish because they haven't
been up with the times they haven't been
able to adapt for the
changing regulations or the changing
legal landscape
and i think that's going to be even more
so moving forward
um so bonus we've got jhan's survival
guide
so um i think this is specifically about
jhan's
advice for credibility and cbd
companies so you know
be these are kind of like red flags
right so watch out for anybody who's
uh boasting about accomplishments that
were a long time ago
anybody who's you know
accomplishments were like oh i used to
bark at this particular tv show in the
80s
now i sell cpd to kids so
you know just be aware of that we do
have a
um a source slide right here so these
are going to be all the different
organizations we talked about
including where i got that quote um and
then lastly
i wanted to talk about um i wanted to
talk about how people can get involved
with can because
again it is so near and dear to my heart
uh we are taking
applications for the el solle award
sponsored by hudolp north america
that is applications are due
july 1st with
you can get a hold of us from that
general email
that general email box on the website
which is on the flyer right there
and um you know we're always looking for
volunteers
we are entirely volunteer run
organization and so
anybody who wants to come and build
their skill set and develop a really
cool
[Music]
group of colleagues this is a great way
to do it it's a great networking
opportunity to
to meet some of your cannabis colleagues
this way
we are 700 plus members today
and i believe in august we'll be
applying for full division status at the
american chemical society so jumping
from subdivision to division
and it's a really exciting step because
it means a permanent home
at the american chemical society and
really we get to
sort of write our own rules to some
extent so that's really exciting
and we're growing fast 10 new members a
month doubled our membership in 2019
um and you know
we're really excited to move forward uh
here
some of the things we might be doing in
the not so distant future
creating the journal of cannabis
chemistry
we do a monthly webinar series the um
call it journal club um and that is free
to anybody who'd like to join
um and we also have a quarterly
newsletter for members
and we're working on exciting things
which
may be too early to mention but so i'll
hold my tongue but you can follow us at
can d chas on most of the social media
platforms and then also our website is
canachem.org
for the time being which i believe is
going to change uh pretty soon
but um but that's what it is at the
moment
so i want to thank you guys for your
time today and i hope everybody
is doing well and uh and don't hesitate
to
reach out to me with questions uh via
email
and i'll do my best to respond to you as
soon as i get them
thank you very much